See, that's the difference between being
brought up in the 70s and being brought
up now. I just walk in, look at the
teddy, pick it up, put it back, and walk
off again. Good. True. But would you not
wonder why it tipped over? No. At all?
No. Come on. You must. No.
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from to Isa. If
you want to support someone like me in
learning salah, then sponsor 10 people
for just £100 this Ramadan. Remember the
prophet peace be upon him said, "Charity
does not decrease wealth. Click the
button and donate now."
Why did I choose Islam 11 years ago?
Because I believed even though there's
not much that of a standard on men of
how we look to us it's more like you
know what we earn and you know what kind
of jobs we have etc for that matter but
to me I can remember I used to go
clubbing in central London every week
and there used to be a specific jumper I
used to wear. I looked I believed I
looked really handsman but people yeah
literally. So I used I used I used to
wear that and um and it was itchy. You
know that material that makes you itch?
Oh. Oh. Oh, I hate I hated it. But you
wore it because I look good in Yeah. So
to me it was like I was like what's the
difference between me and what girls
when when they're wearing like seven in
heels or in a mini skirt in freezing
cold and some of them have to like we
we're there like in Leicester Square and
we see like girls just taking off their
heels and walking bare like n barefoot
and it's freezing cold. So I would
relate to that and I like oh my gosh
that's how I was and I was thinking to
myself what made me become like that?
And then I was reading the question and
I was like it's because societal
pressures like a lot of us think we um
we're free like we think yeah no I'm
free I choose to do I'm like yeah of
course we believe in free will but we're
actually influenced by so many factors
be it TV be our friends be the opposite
gender uh be it phone people being on
their phone scrolling scrolling
scrolling banners they got popular yeah
exactly and knowing that they they they
give you a perception um of how the
world should be and your expectations so
when you when you're being so immersed
Because I don't believe we only consume
with what we eat. We consume with our
eyes. That's why they say the heart
doesn't desire what the eyes don't see,
you know? And we're watching all this
stuff and we have people and I was like
I was a victim of that. And there's so
many other people who when you look at
them and like okay why do you dress like
that or why do you choose to do that? Is
it cuz you want to or cuz you
subconsciously been told to exactly peer
pressure. So to me when I was looking
into different religions I I started
reading the Bible first when I told you
I was in I was in a relationship in
before Islam. Um she her mom was white
her dad was Pakistani and I used
celebrate Christmas and Easter with them
and they they used to have a Bible
started reading the Bible cuz I was like
I mean there must be more to my purpose
because I looked around like the room
actually. It all started off with my
socks and I'll tell you why. I know my
my socks can be quite smelly at times,
but this this story is going to be
smelling nice. I looked at my socks and
I was like, my socks have a specific uh
shape and they are designed. They have a
purpose cuz when you have socks, you
know, you don't put your socks in your
head. I mean, there might be some people
who do that. You can feel you can feel
free to do that. Yeah, depends on how
small your head is. So, to me, I was
like, my socks are designed for my feet.
They have a purpose. And I was like, how
could it be how could it be that my
socks have a purpose, but me as a human
being? I'm quite I'm more complex than
designed. Like my kidney, my heart, my
liver, these are all I'm like a machine.
And I was like, if my mere socks have a
designer, what's my purpose? Like what's
my purpose? You know, everything has a
purpose. Your earrings, your jacket,
your shoes, everything in this house has
a purpose. The walls, you know, the
lights. Um, and I thought to myself, I
mean, what's my purpose? Why what am I
doing here? It's like the existential
crisis. It's like, why am I here? Where
am I going? You know, I didn't choose my
mom and dad. I didn't choose my name. I
didn't choose the way I look. You know,
you know, I didn't choose uh to be
handsome. No, I'm joking. I'm joking.
Like, do you have a chance to say, do
you not ever think to yourself like, why
am I here? It's quite a deep thought,
isn't it? It is, is it? Have you Have
you ever had that thought? No, I don't
think further than beyond what am I
going to eat later?
Sorry. When's my next bit of food
coming? I'm a bit like that as well
after the existential crisis when I
figured that out. Yeah. To me, it's
Allah food hours. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah.
Yeah. To me it was just like why am I
here? Like and it's it's whatever you
have in the worldly life. It's you come
to a moment where you're just like there
must be a greater purpose. It's I don't
believe in um I just popped here by
accident or I was just just randomness
and atoms collided with each other. So
to me that's when I I always believed in
some kind of a create like a creator.
But to me it wasn't nothing um it wasn't
personal. It was just like, okay, I
believe there's a higher power there.
But yeah, that that that made me
realize, okay, um, all this time I've
been following like my desires and my
wants and peer pressure and friends and
family, whatever. But I said to myself,
well, I'm I'm actually a slave. If you
think about it, we're all um there was a
philosopher, I forgot his name, he said,
man is born uh man is born free, but
he's in shackles everywhere. So like we
have things that we are um forced to do
indirectly. So that's where I the reason
I picked Islam is because Islam number
one it has evidence. It doesn't tell you
to blind like blindly believe. It
doesn't tell you yeah this is God exists
and it's a fairy tale. It doesn't it
tells you actually to question. God
Almighty tells you like do you not look
around like the heavens and the earth
and the night and day and within
yourself you know like you know my
fingerprint doesn't match your
fingerprint or seven eight billion
people's fingerprints. Like we are
composed of like DNA and DNA is like a
program. It's like you know like your
computer it's programmed. So to me it
was like okay DNA is information. If
there's information it requires
intelligence. So that was the things
that pointed me out to like to accept
that there's number one I have a
purpose. Number two I'm designed. It's
clear that I'm I mean there's a design
purp? Yeah it's unique as well. Yeah. So
yeah that was my uh journey. That's the
reason why I believe there's a high
power. But with with yourself you you
don't you're an atheist. I wouldn't say
I'm anything. I just don't think about
any of it. My brain doesn't work that
way really. If I can't see it, then it's
not there. My dad But my dad's then my
dad's an athe atheist. Sometimes he can
become agnostic. I say that's that's a
that's that's someone that probably
don't believe. I mean, I think the day
you're born, the day you die is stamped
on your head. Yes. I don't think you can
change it. Some people like they don't
go full term in their pregnancy. Some
people go over. Some people live to
whatever. Some people live to hund and
some. I don't think you can change
those. But I don't think too much about
the bit in the middle. Okay. I don't
tend to think too much about anything in
life. So it's not just religion. Why am
I here? I go for a walk down the street.
I don't think to myself in half an
hour's time it's going to be raining and
I need to feel I need to cover that.
Especially with British weather. I just
I come from a generation we just do. We
just exist. Don't overthink. We wasn't
taught to overthink.
wasn't taught to question anything
really. Really? Yeah. No, we didn't
really question anything. We did as
little as possible cuz we just wanted to
get out and play. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Would you? Yeah. So, even like going out
and play like would you not plan your
day like for example Oh, okay. Not plan.
I'll be honest with you. Even myself
like when it comes to I don't usually
like the plan as well. I'm bit
spontaneous. But leaving the house, I
leave it with some kind of a purpose of
like even if I'm going to go for a walk,
I want to walk just cuz I want to get
some fresh air. Okay. Um like we we do
have some like um logic and rational
behind stuff that we do. Like when we
cross the road for example, you you
wouldn't just blindly cross the road and
say, "Oh, you'd look." Yeah. Exactly.
Cross the road cuz the sun was shining.
Yeah. Exactly. Good. Yeah. So what I'm
saying is when you cross the road, you
use your rationale by saying, "Okay, let
me look left and right in case a car
hits me." What when you do that, that
what that does is it obviously you you
number one accept that you exist. Yeah.
Yeah. Which I'm sure you do. Don't tell
me you don't say you don't you don't
exist. Yeah. Exist. Yeah. So that one.
Exactly. And you want to look left and
right not to not exist. Exactly. Yeah.
Exactly. Exactly. So we we say that we
use these our logic and rational on a
day-to-day basis. Like when you wake up
today, when you woke up today, you
didn't wake up and say maybe I'm on Mars
or maybe I'm in Pluto or maybe I'm in a
jungle. You know you're in your house.
Yeah. I do wake up and go what day is
it? Yeah. Exactly. And that's not
what Hang on. What did I do yesterday?
Okay, good. First drink, then that's not
What did I do yesterday? Yeah, exactly.
So, when you wake up, like if you go to
your fridge and you see a bunny there,
like a a rabbit, you you won't you won't
be like, "Oh, that's just normal."
You'll be like, "That's odd. Why is
there Why is there a bunny in the
fridge?" Exactly. Leave it for someone
else to buy. Exactly. Yeah. So, so these
are things like they even done a study
with um like young kids. They they they
they had a table and they would let them
observe. They wanted to see if the like
certain realities if they are if they've
been taught or it's intuition like
something that they have internally. So
what they would do is they would use
magnetic forces I think and they would
make it seem as if the the item a toy
doesn't fall off the table. So it goes
to the edge of the table but it just
carries on going. So they look if the
kid sees it as abnormal or be like oh
it's magic magic or whatever it is for
that matter but they noticed the kids
found it odd they were like okay tip of
the table it should fall but it wasn't
it was carry on going. So they they
realized the kids actually noticed which
showed which they scientists say they
they've seen that as the kids
intuitionally they realize that's not
normal that's odd and they were think
they were thinking it's not something
that is taught it's something that we
have intuition we've programmed to know
that's odd that shouldn't happen like
the bunny in the in the fridge that
should not be there um for example if
you came home today and you saw the TV
tipped over um I mean depends I don't
know how you feel But who cares? What's
my next food? What am I going to eat on
the next meal? I wouldn't think I got
there that much. Exactly. But you might
look at team and be like, "Was my house
robbed?" Or you go through some
possibilities. Number one, someone tried
to rob my house. Number two, there was a
mini earthquake. Number three, what's
the dog's name? Shan. Shhan. Who named
him? Shan took over.
Shan. Shan took it over. Can you imagine
someone say he took the TV over? Shh.
Oh, that famous guy. No, it's my dog.
The dog's very famous.
Then we have the gender arrow. Yes. The
pronouns. Yes. It's We don't know the
pronouns of the dog. So, you will come
to certain conclusions where you'll be
like, "Okay, it's one of these things,
but you'll never think maybe a blue
dragon flew through my house and tip the
TV over."
See, that's the difference between being
brought up in the 70s and being brought
up now. I'd just walk in, look at the
tail, pick it up, put it back, and walk
off again. Good. True. But would you not
wonder why it tipped over? No. At all.
No. Come on. You must. No, I wouldn't.
I'd think either it just fell off or
Good. Well, I suppose. Yeah, I would.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Good. I wouldn't
question it. Good. Good. Okay. No. Okay.
No problem. You would accept the TV
fell. We all would be, "Okay, the TV's
falling." It's weird stuff happens.
Magic. I believe in magic. Yeah. Like we
we as we believe as well. There's the
metaphysical world. We believe in
they're called the gins. We believe that
we can't. That's a ghost, isn't it? Kind
of. Yeah. See, the only gin I believe in
is when you put on Yeah. Generally, I
can remember that. Yeah. So, it's it's
that that reality what that that
conclusion that we do, we use it on our
day-to-day basis with everything. Like
when I came in today, you know, you was
expecting me, you know, you was
expecting the chocolates and the
flowers. Of course, was you? Chocolates,
but not flowers. That's good. Yeah. See,
that was a surprise. It was a nice
surprise. There you go. So when you when
you when you saw that obviously it's
certain expectation and you know I hope
it brought happiness to your face or you
was happy about it. Yeah. Unfortunately
flowers to an English girl mean what's
he done wrong?
Oh not me. Yeah. So uh well not just not
just yet. Yeah. So u yeah. So we we use
our rationale and logic when it comes to
this stuff like you know when you used
to go work you know you knew you know
like okay when I go work you're not
going to turn up to work and be like oh
the building doesn't exist. We knew
these realities. So we say that um these
are things that we need to have
day-to-day living otherwise everything
it's everything becomes uncertain. So
you you accept it anyways that there's
those realities like today you're going
to what are you cooking or are you
cooking? You don't cook. No. It's okay.
All right. Who's who's cooking? No one.
Aisha. No. Oh okay. Do do you toast? You
toast cereals. I'm not a student. Oh,
okay. Okay, that's good. Yeah. I mean uh
Have you tried peanut butter? Um I don't
like peanut butter. You don't really?
Have you ever tried peanut? Have you
ever tried peanut butter jam? You know,
I can I can remember. I haven't. Peanut
butter is wrong. Really? Yeah. I I I I
can
remember. That's wrong as well. Oh, mm I
tried it once actually. It wasn't bad at
all. I'm not going to lie. I've tried
Marmite. You know they say you either
love it or you hate it. Who didn't have
peanut butter when I was a kid? You had
jam. Really? Yeah. Oh my peanut butter
jam. Have you tried peanut butter jam?
Bro, peanut butter jam when I was
introduced to it, I was like, "Oh my
gosh, I've been missing that all my
life." Yeah. But it's not for everybody.
Some people have allergies. Yeah. So, uh
again, toast when when you make toast.
Yeah. Yes. You you you agree that you
need a toast machine? Yes. Yes. You
agree you need a toast? Yeah. You need
jam. Awesome. Bonfire. Come on.
Not a big toast, a small toast. Yeah.
So, so today you know for example that
you are going to probably get hungry and
you're going to go and make a toast with
jam. Yeah. Okay. Good. So, or probably
just eat the box of chocolates you
bought. Exactly. Exactly. You're not
going to share. No. Okay. Just not
sharing. Okay. We're going to have to
buy one. So, so what I'm saying is that
when it comes to these stuff, like I
know what you mean. Like my dad says
that as well. He's like, "Look, I don't
worry myself with this stuff. Who's
there? What's the extra job? But the
thing is it's that stress you out.
It can it can but like I think it it
doesn't require too much thinking
because it's something that is a reality
for example existing. So when you're
existing you would have to say that it's
like you came from somewhere your mom.
Yeah. But if we go to the beginning, we
would have to accept that the creation
started. Like for example, a lot of
philosophers ask the question, why is
there something rather than
nothing? Like why is there something?
Why does there something? Because if
there was nothing, we wouldn't be asking
the question. Good. So because we're
here, the question is why are we here?
And like what's caused us? Like you
would accept that if your mother didn't
give birth to you would not be here. M
so what we say is that going all the way
back who created the first human beings
that gave rice to us you know like even
for example I was doing some studies
about our like bacteria in our body and
I want to show you something it's
actually quite profound it's you know
the bacteria in our body there's they
have tails so these little bacteria they
have tail they swim around uh your gut
you have it around the world by the way
you have in the sea different places so
it's like good and bad bacteria but they
looked at on a microscopic level yeah I
want to show you their tail the tail's
called the fleellum. Yeah. Yeah. I know
it sounds funny when I was it. It sounds
funny. I want to show you what the tail
looks like. And I was like I found it so
profound. So this is a
picture. So this is the tail, right? So
So there that's the bacteria. That's the
tail that propels it. Okay. So in our
stomach that flies around like you know
sometimes upset in our tummy. That that
there is a um basically on a microscopic
level four billion of these fit in a
half a teaspoon. So we just know how
what we're dealing it's like that's how
small they are. That is like an engine.
It's like a it's like a you know like a
Ferrari know that you know it's it's
like an engine composed of 40 pieces. So
when I saw that I was I actually I got a
little mini anxiety. I was like that is
actually so profound like this. It's
made out of 40 parts. And I was saying
to
myself, what do you think? Because it's
intentionally built. It's not
spontaneous. It's intentionally built
for that purpose that that bacteria uses
the tail to propel itself to go to
places around our body and around the
world. So when looking at that, would
you not say that's
designed? Like doesn't it look like some
kind of a design? Like when we look at a
car engine? Yeah, I'd say it was
designed, but unfortunately my brain
don't work like that. So you'd show me
that and I wouldn't think to myself, oh,
that's been designed. I'd just look at
that and go, okay, oh, so I got that in
my stomach. Have I? And okay, good. All
right. Interesting. All right, that's
good. That's good. Okay. No, that's
that's that's good. Cuz to me, it's when
I first saw that as well, it was like,
okay, that's quite profound. I didn't
know they actually exist or even look
like that on such a microscopic level.
But with a little bit of deep deep
analysis, a bit of analysis, would you
not say, hold on a second, like that's
intentional. That cannot be by chance
because it's composed of 40 pieces. So
they all have to work together in order
for those bacteras and bear in mind four
billion of them fit in a two teaspoon.
That's how small they are. Would do you
not say if that is just the bacteria in
my tummy and one of their tails look
like this. Imagine your your um your
whole body like for you to be talking to
me now. There's muscles involved. Your
heart's beating, your kidneys are
filtering blood, your liver's
functioning. There's so many other No,
that's all right. That's fine. We we we
spoke to him already. Yeah. See, he
believes in
God. He just he just became a
Muslim. Yeah. So looking at that would
you not say that's intentional and there
must be a higher power which has given
rise to us and for us to obviously the
first stage I would say is to accept
that there is some some kind of a higher
power who's intentionally made you me
these bacterias the dog and every order
that we have on on on our planet think I
must be stupid okay because honestly I
wouldn't think that Okay. Look at I
think you're obviously much more
intelligent than me and you like No, I'm
not. Believe me. Believe me, I'm not. I
think that's a compliment. I don't think
I am.
It's not a bit more clever than